well I'm as all of your audience
probably can already tell I'm Jewish
greetings of peace my next guest Max
Blumenthal declare that he's fighting
Human animals in Gaza as Israel cuts off
the gas the water and the electricity I
went to Hebrew school during the
1980s Long Live Israel God Bless America
you guys out here to support Israel yep
radical Muslims must be defeated unless
we're going to all ruin the whole
Western Civilization because Israel is
for Jews
since the beginning of the Bible that's
number one number two the Arabs have no
right to be there they are forcing us to
kill their children to defend our
children yes how much do we have to bomb
them before there's peace no matter how
long they must be bomb yeah how many
schools do we have to blow up before
there's
peace well we have advanced technology
Israel knows what schools Hamas is
hiding in correct and then they blow up
the whole school they they very
intelligent yes they hiding in school
they're making bombs under the desks
exactly those who are dying are
suffering God's Wrath but but don't I
seem like a good Jew you don't seem like
a good Jew but who am I to judge the
editor and chief of the gray zone max
Blumenthal is an
awardwinning journalist and the author
of several books Max has contributed to
the New York Times Los Angeles Times and
much more now being the awardwinning
journalist that he is he's debunked much
of the atrocity propaganda that we still
keep hearing over and over again that's
fueling the continued push for modern
genocide in 4k right before our very
eyes all human life is precious and this
needs to stop so for example I'm going
to go ahead and play this clip from our
friend Pierce
Morgan and let's uh listen to this and
then we'll bring on Max blumthal to go
and cover this ter do you have proof
that they targeted women and children
civilians specifically what's the proof
I'll tell you the proof what's the proof
the GoPro videos oh you don't think it
happened oh the GoPro videos so we so
like the doctor you deny no I've seen
the videos I'm a journalist I've
authenticated the videos I've seen the
videos but show me the proof that women
and children were specifically targeted
as opposed to they were literally burned
alive okay where's the proof people were
beheaded proof babies were killed name
me one child one child was beheaded name
me one child that was beheaded and I
will mourn and condemn with you I just
said people were beheaded I didn't say a
child not primary S objetive no no so
just to be clear to be clear like the
doctor you do not believe that anyone
was beheaded that children were killed
let me clarify where I'm wrong here were
were these things
happening Israeli civilians were killed
how many I don't know Mark Greer doesn't
even know we need to First establish
they do know many we know at least 1200
including around 400 uh soldiers so
we're assuming 800 civilians were killed
and we know at least many at least over
200 odd civilians were taken hostage
right were killed by Israel and ladies
and gentlemen brothers and sisters Max
Blumenthal how are you doing Max good
good to see you good to have you on
interesting intro I I forgot I'd written
for the New York Times and was allowed
to do that once upon a time yeah so you
have an extensive history uh you're
doing what journalism should be all
about uh spreading the truth truth and
highlighting the truth but you've also
debunked a lot of things that um many
people are saying it's not the truth and
uh there's an example with Pierce Morgan
what was your reaction to
that well just because Pierce Morgan
doesn't know something doesn't mean that
it it's not true and that's the way he
operates he has this kind of a tendency
to impose his own prejudices onto
reality and then to use his image as a
sort of objective
newsman to make his guests seem like
lunatics and his guests when he tries to
make them seem lunatics they often
happen to be activists or Muslims or
people out of the mainstream um so they
just don't appear objective to his
audience it's all a series of sort of
psychological tricks he's using
and um was that Dilly Hussein who is his
guest yes do you know Dilly yeah I I
honestly he could have done a better job
he could have been more clinical um in
Po in providing concrete examples of
Israel killing its own citizens and
citing Israeli media and that's sort of
what but I mean it's it's an important
for it's important for him to raise that
issue in front of a mainstream audience
but that's what I've been doing at the
gry zone and what other independent
Outlets have been doing is just giving
people who have this sense that what
happened on October 7th is not only
shrouded in mystery but represents a
series of distortions that were used and
deployed in order to create political
space for this un this just un this
despicable genocide that we see playing
out before our eyes and so what we're
doing is we're providing you know it's
you you have a a sandwich of skepticism
you have the breads laid out and we're
providing the deli meats for you uh
translating the Hebrew news pieces news
packages where they're actually for the
first time this week showing tanks
shelling Israeli homes in kibuts Berry
where over 100 Israeli non-combatants
were killed they're showing the tanks in
those communities during the day
shelling those homes um we've also been
able
to uh provide translations of Israeli
eyewitnesses who witnessed Israeli tanks
after it grew dark so a separate tank
shelling a civilian home knowing that
that home was was filled with 15 Israeli
hostages including two children who were
12 years old twins the hetron twins who
were killed by that Israeli tank who've
been used as poster children by the
Israeli
leadership uh as examples of you know
Hamas savagery that's not to say that
Hamas militants didn't kill civilians on
October 7th that there's there's video
documenting that but we don't know how
many people is Israel killed and the
number seems to be very high uh
considering the heavy weapons they were
using MH how did you what led you down
this path of Journalism uh because you
have many journalists they're not even
as I understand correctly they're not
even allowed to go into without escorts
is that correct me if I'm ever wrong
here uh they're not allowed they need an
a a company with the um IDF and how did
you and and then you go against the
narrative and you put your career on the
line how did you you're talking about
how did I get into Gaza no how did you
just uh start reporting on Gaza ex so
before this happened you were actually
um reporting on this and you were on the
ground is that correct yeah well I'm I'm
as all of your audience probably can
already tell I'm Jewish uh one of your
partners also who helped make the film
killing Gaza I interviewed him he's also
Jewish that's very interesting I had no
idea you're Jewish also wow well there
are plenty of us who wow you know are
disgust who are disgusted by Dan Cohen
it was Dan Cohen yes yeah I mean he grew
up in a much more um all all immersive
Jewish experience than I did but you
know I grew up in Washington
DC and I um you know I went to Hebrew
school during the 1980s and 90s and you
know the first inata broke out around
that time I wasn't heavily indoctrinated
into Zionism but I wound up going on the
birthright Israel trip later in life
when I was like 22 and that's a free
trip that all Jews 18 to 25 get to go to
Israel and that really showed me um not
only
what the the the propaganda version of
Israel that was presented to me what
they wanted me to believe about Israel
but the complete contrast between the
the worldview of Israelis and M
um you know I remember my guide sitting
me down because I had made some sort of
humanistic statements and the second Ina
was about to break out and she said we
have to see all different groups uh and
religions and races as circles and we
have to take our Circle and put it above
all those other circles and it was sort
of like opening it it sort of began this
process of of gradual black pilling and
red pilling first of all I'm never going
to be able to be a Zionist which means
I'm gonna be cut off from much of my
community and I'm going to be woken up
to you know what the the reality the
reality that Palestinians are living in
I had never met a Palestinian by that
point and then I got into journalism
because of the post 911 era um just
seeing the lies that Americans were
consuming constantly as the so-called
war on terror was declared and then the
invasion of
Iraq um
these uh were
obviously going to lead the US and the
region into a terrible abyss and so I
started doing journalism just about the
Bush Administration and about the
Christian right and the
neoconservatives and all along I was you
know following the situation in Israel
Palestine waiting for the day when I
could actually make my move and start to
educate Americans about the real Israel
they didn't know that came after my
first book which happened to to sort of
be a bestseller which was more about the
the Republican party of George W bush
and I said I said to my publisher I said
I just gave you a bestseller you didn't
expect that at all how about you give me
uh the opportunity to write a book about
Israel and they agreed miraculously and
I said okay I'm gonna take a trip there
scope things out I took a trip went to
you know Jerusalem Tel Aviv the West
Bank this was 2009 started covering the
unarmed struggle in the West Bank where
Palestinians and Villages that were cut
off by the apartheid wall were beginning
uh this sort of popular struggle that
wasn't being covered in the west that
cut against the grain of the image of
Palestinians as suicide bombers and
terrorists and they're simply defending
their land being arrested in their beds
I got to know Israeli Society I remember
the night of Obama's speech in Cairo um
his sort of speech to the Arab world
which should now be looked back looked
back at as sort of a moment of infamy I
went out on the streets of Jerusalem to
ask um Jewish Israelis and Jewish
Americans what they thought of the
speech and each one of them Unleashed
this genocidal tirade right on camera
and I found all these bars where drunken
Jewish Americans were coming out and
just telling me how they wanted to
assassinate Obama um and how Netanyahu
is going to take care of him and how
Israel was going to take care of him if
he uh pushed ahead with peace with the
pales Ians and they said he's a Muslim
and all the all of that I put that video
out on YouTube um was like you know one
of I mean I I I was already doing all
these viral YouTube videos about uh the
Christian rot or Christian Zionist so I
had a fairly strong Channel and within
two hours it had 500,000 views it was
blowing up uh Black America was seeing
the video and they were disgusted it was
reported on local New York news cuz a
lot of these kids were from Long Island
and then the next thing I know YouTube
Took the takes the video offline it was
censored on every channel I was like one
of the first victims of the censorship
industrial complex for exposing the
racism of Israeli Society but that kind
of set the stage for the book that I was
going to do which was called Goliath
which really if you if you pick up my
book Goliath life and Loathing in
Greater Israel which came out in 2013 it
will really show you the help you
understand the basis for how Israelis
are so indoctrinated that they can cut
off hundreds of lives with the push of a
button knowing that they're going to
kill dozens of babies with one bombing
and feel good about themselves the next
day the the book is a a trip into it's a
journey into the heart of Jewish Israeli
society and I used my privilege as an
American Jew you know I'm treated with
special privilege in Israeli Society um
to be able to get access to that and I I
subsequently did another book called The
51 Day War which which is about Israel's
assault on Gaza in 2014 and I got um
press access from the Israeli government
to be able to go in then and at that
point you didn't need to be like
embedded with the Israeli military they
weren't even there at that point they
were just bombing from the air through
drones and so on they just handed me a
card and said go ahead um they were
handing him out like like candy at that
point so I got to be under the bombing
uh that people in Gaza experience day
after day and I got to be in the rubble
and you know I started filming that
documentary you mentioned uh with Dan
Cohen killing Gazo which is free
online and I've been covering Israel
Palestine ever since at the gray Zone
what we do is we unpack the propaganda
that
deluges uh Western media consumers day
after day pro-war propaganda pro-
interventionist propaganda and we help
people understand the other side and we
also go to countries that are targets of
Western regime change operations
including in Latin America like we've
done a lot in Venezuela Nicaragua bivia
places where the US does not want these
countries to be independent and have
access to their own resources and with
October 7th it pulled me back in to
Israel Palestine back into this malstrom
in a much more intense way than I've
ever experienced like uh all Western
journalists I can't go to Gaza I don't
even know if Israel will let me in at
this point because I've kind of been
marked um so I'm just sitting here at
home in Washington DC unpacking the
propaganda and helping uh people
understand how they're basically being
tricked into supporting a genocide let's
get into this next clip and you're
probably going to recognize this uh
individual and he's talking about some
video that the general public hasn't
seen we've seen some of it but this is
like some private private session for
jour J I want to see if you know or if
you've seen this video like I said
today's been a heavy day um because uh
three of us went to the Israeli
consulate to watch some of the footage
uh that we've never seen these images
and um media a lot of it raw some of it
um they did some editing too to identify
things of what happened in the massacre
on October 7th it's 47 minutes long now
some of it I have seen before and you
can find it online a lot more than I
expected was new to me I realized
something that I had missed before okay
it took me immediately and deeply into a
past trauma the exact feeling that I had
when I learned why 911 happened charred
reminders of a
holocaust the obvious desire to see as
many Jews utterly destroyed as possible
families melted together on purpose and
yes there are
women dead bloody groins Twisted
disfigured legs the IDF says this is not
a morbid coincidence it's a part of a
pattern of rape and torture well before
we even started uh you um you had a
little reaction
you're you're you're familiar the last
part he's described the last part you're
familiar with
KO yeah Chris Cuomo I'm very familiar
with he was fired by CNN and he's on
this uh network of like the hasbin
who've all been fired um with Bill
O'Reilly he was fired because he was
helping his brother Andrew Cuomo write
uh you know prepare messaging during the
covid event uh when Andrew Cuomo was
like getting an Emmy Award for his daily
press conferences and it was all this
giant performance and he was promoting
his brother it was complete nepotism
Cuomo was also one of the like thickest
mentally thickest people on the on the
air and there's a lot of competition
there um if you look at his Instagram
all he does is lift weights you don't
see him reading books or engaging with
uh intelligent people in any way it's
just him showcasing his muscles and
showing off in the gym where he spends
like four hours a day and you can see
that he was an easy dupe for the Israeli
government uh they brought him into a 47
minute screening they've been bringing
in so-called journalists to an off- thee
reccord so-called screening where you're
not allowed to really disclose the
details of what you see you're only
allowed to refer on background generally
to what you see you're not really
allowed to ask
questions as a journalist and you're not
allowed to videotape or take photos of
the proceedings so why would any
journalist allow themselves into that
kind of Clockwork Orange style
propaganda complex if they're a real
journalist they wouldn't um and what
Chris Cuomo is describing at the end is
seeing uh the remnants of corpses who
were hit by Hellfire missiles by Israeli
helicopters on their
way from Southern Israel to Gaza or just
simply while um being in their
cars in Israel some of them may have
even been trying to escape from the Nova
Electronic Music Festival it is a
confirmed fact that Israeli Apache
helicopters killed many people in their
vehicles and while walking on the fields
this is this is not this is not some
conspiracy theory or something this is
confirm fact I mean that it's confirmed
by an Israeli police investigation which
was reported in haritz it's confirmed by
uh abductees who had been freed from
Gaza Israeli abductees who complained
about Israeli aache helicopter shooting
at their vehicles while they were
heading into Gaza they complained to
netanyahu's face during a war cabinet
meeting earlier this month it was
reported in the Israeli newspaper wet uh
we have video of the helicopters hitting
cars and we have testimony by the
helicopter Pilots about how they
couldn't determine who is Israeli or
Palestinian on the ground but they had
to in their words empty the tank of
their ammunition they had absolutely no
intelligence um and if you look at the
images for example from the highway of
death from the first Iraq war when the
US Air Force incinerated a large part of
the Iraqi military as it retreated from
um Kuwait which was a war crime um
you'll see this they look the corpses
and the cars look almost identical to
those in the so-called Gaza envelope of
Southern Israel on October 7th there's
no way that the weapons that Hamas
militants brought in could have done
that kind of comprehensive ensive damage
to bodies where they're melted into
parts of
cars that a Hellfire missile can do and
in one case I mean this is going to
sound kind of rabbit hole but this is
something I was able to figure out I
actually had to take it out of one of my
articles because it was just uh there
there's too many details but you might
be familiar with the story of how um
this so-called Israeli rescuer named
Ellie Beer went to a Republican Jewish
Coalition fundraiser in Las Vegas and
claimed that his rescue group on October
7th found a baby baked in an oven the
story really got around totally fake um
the organization itself is even sort of
retracted that story when they were
asked by the Israeli newspaper harats it
comes from someone in his organization
who said that they found body parts that
had been uh melted into a heating
element you know the kind of heating
element you'd have in an oven and they
found those body parts at this kind of U
military based field Hospital Israel
setup um in an Israeli city called ramay
where they analyze all of the evidence
and corpses of October 7th okay the
heating element was actually a car seat
that has Springs in it that are shaped
like a heating element and
somebody was hit by a Hellfire missile
which led their skin to melt into the
car seat and then the that piece of body
part was taken to this Israeli field
hospital where they basically saw it and
said oh my God this looks like someone
was baked in an oven let's just say that
to invoke the Holocaust so Chris CUA was
just being treated to these images and
they're telling him they may be even
guiding him through it he has the IQ of
a toaster oven himself and he's
uncapable of critical thought or
skepticism and so he then says this is
911 this was genocide and he actually
thinks that the US response to 911 was
successful and positive the US response
to 911 was a first of all a military
failure does he remember the US
retreated from Afghanistan and lost to
the Taliban in one of the most
disastrous military withdrawals since
Vietnam has he forgotten that has he
forgotten the entire military response
was a failure and that the only
successful possibility was a police
action against Osama Bin Laden at toror
which itself failed so everything Chris
Cuomo is saying there is false and this
is what the American Media consumers are
being treated to which is why there was
a poll I think taken by Harvard last
week which found that the majority of
Americans think Hamas is determined to
commit genocide and only about 35% think
Israel has the intention of doing that
let's get into this next uh clip here
get your reaction to um
this used to defeat them used to kill
them and one thing I saw is that whether
you live in the North or the south of
Israel whether you're religious or
secular everyone agreed and united we
can no longer Embrace this being Mr Nice
Guy to the people who are in Gaza
because this is over a thousand years of
mothers teaching their children grow up
and kill Jews grow up and kill Jews it's
the mind they're trying to paint this
narrative that uh Muslims just intrin
intrinsically they're taught you know to
hate Jews um I have a lot of Jewish
friends that I've had on the program you
might know some Orthodox rabbis I don't
know if you know heard of Miko pillet um
Rabbi Weiss Rabbi Shapiro and and they
differentiate clearly Zionism uh between
Zionism and Judaism and they say that
Judaism has been hijacked by Zionism and
now they're trying to paint this picture
to the to the mainstream audience and
she's repeating the same thing that this
is uh their survival they're going to be
killed by Muslims if they don't um go
ahead if they put down if they stop what
what do you hear as a Jewish man when
you hear
this well a thousand years ago Jews and
Muslims were getting along fairly well
and uh you know my mades was
corresponding with ibben Rush uh uh in
in the endal Luan experience wasn't
anything like the European experience
Michelle Bachmann um someone who uh you
know is
in Chris Cuomo maybe below Chris Cuomo's
intelligence quotient um believes that
Palestinian mothers have been raising
their children to hate Jews for a
thousand years uh she doesn't even I
guess remember the Christian Crusades
where um Jews and Muslims actually
resisted the Christian Onslaught in
Jerusalem she knows nothing about
history she's at Charlie Kirk's
conference his recent conference um
which is sort of conservative
conservatism Incorporated it's basically
corporate conservatism and she went on
to deliver a tirade there calling for
everyone in Gaza to be ethnically
cleansed full-on ethnic cleansing and to
turn Gaza into um some kind of nature
reserve one second let me let the
audience hear hear that they have one
industry in Gaza and that's terrorism so
it's time that Gaza ends the 2 million
people who live there they are clever
assassins they need to be removed from
that land that land needs to be turned
into a national park and since they're
the voluntary mercenaries for Iran they
need to be dropped on the doorstep of
Iran let Iran deal with those people is
that she's pretty much saying to 2
million people I mean half which our
children uh that they need to be removed
needs to be made a national how do you
interpret
that yeah I mean she's calling for
genocide and the irony is she has been
appointed as Dean this is a former
member of Congress from Minnesota who is
a very prominent member of the Christian
right um and she has been appointed as
dean of Pat Robertson's Regent
University Pat Robertson being one of
the most
prominent T evangelists in American
history and con artists and Believers in
uh Christian Zion ISM the belief that
you know the Messiah will descend onto
Jerusalem after all of the Jews are
gathered in the land of Israel and the
unclean her heretical Muslims and
Christians are removed um because they
actually don't believe Palestinian
Christians are really Christian because
they're not born again in the blood of
Christ they're Orthodox Christian so
Michelle Bachman comes from that mold
she's been appointed the dean of a
university in America and she is
explicitly calling for genocide in
public
and you have all of these campus
presidents at the same time from The Ivy
Leagues being hauled before Congress who
have never said anything in favor of
genocide being asked to
condemn hypothetical calls for genocide
that have never happened on their
campuses and one from my alma moer the
University of Pennsylvania has already
lost her job as a result of her kind of
wishy-washy answer about a hypothetical
call for genocide that never happened uh
Harvard president is next she's on the
chopping block so that's fine she can
call for genocide there's cu cu uh uh
it's genocide against
Palestinians and you know there's more
to it Charlie Kirk poses as an America
First conservative conservative he's
sort of supposed to be one of the
Grassroots leaders of the Trump movement
but his entire career is owed to the
Israel Lobby his first speaking tours
were originally funded by the David
Horowitz free Freedom Center which is
entirely funded by billionaire zionists
um so he his he owes his career to to a
Lobby that supports an apartheid state
5,000 miles away and yet he's posing as
America First and as a Christian he's
refused to condemn the assaults on
sterious Church in Gaza one of the
oldest churches in the world a fifth
century Orthodox Church he's refused to
condemn Israeli snipers killing women
outside the Latin patriarch Church in
the Gaza Strip he is basically a
Christian frontman for aarth Israel just
like Michelle
Bachman uh this uh is interesting you
mentioned I spoke about this with a
couple of my guests the uh the Christian
Zionism and it links back to this uh
Cyrus scoffield and this
dispensationalism and this um cyber
Scofield bible who was actually a man
and then he went to jail came out so it
seems like all all of this for 1800
years this wasn't even part of
Christianity so uh this is something
that it seems like people also been
duped into believing these fake uh
prophecies that they're trying to uh
fulfill do you know much you know
obviously know much about
this yeah um there's a and I feel I feel
I feel bad because I I feel they've made
it seem like um and if correct me what
what do you think I mean it seems like
uh Christians who are seeing you know
children just being blown to smotherin
massacred because they feel this is a
part of their faith now that they're
sinful if they go against this but then
when I bring on other Christians senior
Christians and uh from Allison Weir from
Americans if Americans only knew if you
have heard of uh her they're saying this
has nothing to do with
Christianity yeah I mean this is a a
uniquely American form of commercial
Christianity
commercial um you know they many them
believe in the Prosperity Gospel that if
you give money to the pastor he will
plant a seed in heaven uh that will
multiply and you yourself will become
rich and of course you just become poor
and the pastor uh becomes extremely
wealthy John heggy is the most prominent
Christian Zionist Pastor in America he
pushes that mentality along with uh
Faith healing uh people who go to his
church believe that he can actually heal
them of their their sicknesses um and
they owe their lives to him and then he
tells them that the Jewish people have
been blessed by God in order to fulfill
biblical prophecy and you have to see
Jews in a sort of fetishistic way as a
special people and defend them in
everything they do and Israel supposedly
represents the Jewish
people and therefore if you don't defend
what Israel's doing in the Gaza Strip
where it's just massacring babies in
this ungodly way day after day with no
regard for human life then you will not
go not only will you not go to heaven
you will not get what's owed to you
after the Rapture uh where where all of
the good Christians who've been born
again will go up to heaven and
experience unbelievable pleasure while
the people who refuseed to submit will
burn in an everlasting Lake of Fire
including many Jews by the way and what
does John Hay get out of that John hegy
has been turned into an extremely
politically powerful and Wealthy figure
by the Israel Lobby which set up his
Christians United for Israel
organization I mean he's been turned
into a national figure that presidential
candidates from the Republican Party
must pay homage to uh every time they
run for office including John McCain who
wasn't even religious um APAC set up his
entire organization so once again you
have a Christian frontman
for a foreign apartheid Lobby uh duping
millions and millions of Americans into
supporting genocide wow this is um deep
there's a lot to package here I mean
this is uh incredible I mean for people
uh you can see you're very well read and
you're very wellers in many of these
things just a few more questions before
we conclude this Hannibal directive you
covered this extensively can you bring
our audience up to speed what is this
directive what is this Hannibal
directive
[Applause]
[Music]
for
[Applause]
[Music]
foree
fore
[Music]
foree
[Applause]
[Music]
fore
for
well just to put it really simply the
Hannibal directive is a once secet
Israeli military policy in which the
Israeli military kills Israeli soldiers
or civilians when they're taken captive
by Palestinians in order to prevent the
kind of politically painful negotiations
that we're seeing Israel forced to
undergo now to get its captives out of
the the Gaza Strip which means letting
go Palestinian captives political
prisoners in Israeli
prisons and uh we saw the Hannibal
directive employed on October 7th on a
massive level when helicopters took aim
at cars on the ground filled with
Israelis when tanks took aim at homes
like the home in which uh the heton
twins the Israeli hetron Twins were
being held captive um it was mass
Hannibal first time the Hannibal
directive came into play after the jbril
agreement in
1986 which was a deal in which Israel
swapped
like maybe as uh over as many as
definitely 3,000 as many as 6,000
Palestinian
prisoners for uh just about three
Israeli soldiers who I think had been
captured by the pfl
PGC it was it was secret and it came out
that this was on the books in
2014 um when Israel when an Israeli
soldier named Colonel Hadar golden was
captured in the Gaza Strip during the
Israeli assault on Gaza on August 1st
2014 that was Black Friday for
Palestinians in the city of Rafa because
when he was captured there Israel rained
down tank shells missiles they brought
all forc to bear in the area where he
was captured in order not only to kill
the team that took him but to kill Hadar
golden himself so that they wouldn't
have to cut a deal for him and they
killed over hundred Palestinian
civilians in the process I was actually
there a few days after I found just
shells and missiles scattered everywhere
marked made in the USA so that came out
that you know Hadar Golden's family was
upset with that and it came out that
they had this secret directive and now
we see it playing out in real time where
you have um over I don't know how many
people were freed in the last prisoner
or captive swap but like over 80 people
and they're all speaking some of them
are speaking out or their families are
speaking out and what they're saying is
at first we were afraid when we went
into the Gaza Strip that Hamas were was
going to kill us then we saw that they
were taking care of us we were important
collateral and we were being bombed
constantly by the Israeli Air Force and
we saw people dying all around us and
our biggest fear was that Israel would
kill us and then they would say Hamas
did it so in many ways this is a kind of
Hannibal directive because you can see
the Israeli leadership does not want to
negotiate for these hostages they don't
want to do it because it's going to
require at least a two- we ceasefire um
and a two-e ceasefire could roll into
something longer um if International
pressure comes to bear so the Hannibal
directive is something that is so
Central to everything we're seeing right
now uh and it goes to the core of the
mentality of Zionism which is a total
disre regard for human life including
the lives of their own citizens so this
henal directive meaning hostages never
taken even if it means killing your own
people is that correct yeah it's named
after the carthaginian general who
killed himself rather than be taken
hostage by the en and then we and then
uh we see this is documented you have
evidence uh police investigation Israeli
police investigation confirms you had
tanks helicopters unloading uh the belly
you had uh Friendly Fire IND
descriminate firing and this is from
Israeli sources the H A TZ haritz haritz
haritz uh so these this is confirmed
this is not any conspiracy based on
Israeli sources that people on October
7th uh who were said to have been killed
by Hamas or other Palestinian militants
were in fact killed by Friendly Fire by
Israeli forces firing
indiscriminately at some of the areas
that were targeted on October 7th and
for that uh you were called conspiracy
theorists including by
hararat but now an official Israeli
police investigation in Israel has
confirmed exactly what you reported
which is that an Israeli helicopter did
hit Israeli Israeli citizens on October
7th now Israeli newspaper is reporting
that an Israeli army helicopter may have
fired on partygoers at the Dance
Festival that was attacked by Hamas f on
October the 7th more than 360 people
were killed at the festival in southern
Israel harritz is quoting an unnamed
police Source citing an investigation
well according to the paper a combat
helicopter arriving at the scene fired
on Hamas Fighters and apparently also
hit some Festival participants so pretty
extraordinary Revelations Hamer talk to
us about this investigation that's being
reported an Israeli attack helicopter
that was dispatch to shoot on Hamas
Fighters at the scene may have
apparently killed some Israelis fleeing
the area as well and then you have um
testimonies from people like yasine
poret and others who are coming out and
confirming the same thing that you also
have reported
on yeah I mean how arts initially called
me a conspiracy theorist from my article
about October 7th that I published in
late
October and now har is claring in an
oped that we need to talk about the
friendly fire deaths on October 7th and
the Hannibal directive um so they're
acknowledging it Israeli Channel 13 just
did a documentary feature on Israeli
tanks shelling Israeli homes on October
7th
[Music]
for
so it's all coming out now um the
problem is the Israeli government is
doing everything it can to bury this
reality because it will cost Netanyahu
his career for sure and it will weaken
the morale of Israeli society as they're
starting to lose lots of soldiers in the
Gaza Strip because their military
operation is is not going that well and
why do you think uh journalists other
journalists like Pierce Morgan who we
opened up the show with why aren't they
discussing these things these important
facts that people should know
about well he's not a journalist I mean
a journalist is someone who's just
naturally skeptical and they don't hold
to one position and they're not also
they're not
uh they're they're not controlled by
fellow Elites and Elite opinion um they
don't need to the journalists is
supposed to exist on the margins and
even accept social isolation but Pierce
Morgan he likes to hang out with fellow
wealthy people including wealthy British
zionists um and he doesn't want to be
castigated so he's just sort of
naturally pro-israel because that's the
mainstream position and he's not someone
who follows uh the he's not someone who
follows a skeptical tendency towards
inconvenient facts and truths um that's
why you see him when he goes up against
Dilly Hussein he can't even believe
someone is saying this to him even if
it's true he has to dismiss it as a
conspiracy theory because he's never
heard it before because he's not a real
journalist he's not that skeptical um I
mean most of the people in our media
class have succeeded precisely because
they are not very intelligent uh they're
not critical thinkers and therefore
they're useful tools for or or useful
stenographers for the powerful forces
that are centered around the National
Security State Pierce Morgan happens to
be one of them I mean just the funny
thing is he he positions himself as
someone who's open to all opinions and
is willing to entertain controversial
views but he's actually a gatekeeper wow
so and people can go and look at most of
these articles um I went on the site gry
Zone it's called The gry Zone and you
have uh for instance you go on I started
reading and there's some I think all
journalists who are in the field I mean
this is very important information
you're bringing to light uh a couple of
them here are Scandal stain Israeli
rescue group fuels October 7
Fabrications that's one report there you
have Israeli tank Gunner reveals orders
to fire indiscriminately into caboots
that's a report Israeli October 7th
poster child was killed by Israeli tank
I eyewitnesses reveal of this is at the
gray Zone
huh it is and uh no one's debunked a
single thing we've wrote no one has
debunked a single thing that you've
wrote no they haven't even har tried and
they called me a master manipulator and
then harat's wound up admitting to
pretty much everything later on wow um
and no one will debate this but if you
read these articles you will find
everything that you're seeing all the
different examples all the lies being
you you'll you'll you'll see it debunked
and everything is sourced um there's
citations for everything um and we also
have a YouTube channel um we do da we do
weekly live streams uh me and my
colleague Aaron mate and we address all
of this propaganda um so we're going to
be live
streaming uh tomorrow and we're also
doing reporting from the ground in Gaza
working with local Gaza journalists and
I think that will provide you with a
perspective that you're definitely not
going to get in mainstream media
um when I get off this stream I'm going
to publish a piece about Israel's attack
on the Nasser Hospital in Khan Yunis
where it attacked a hospital with a tank
shell and killed a 13-year-old girl who
had already been orphaned had lost her
parents and siblings and her leg and
then they killed her in her hospital bed
where are you hearing this story in Us
Media we just all we hear is about the
October 7th hostages and we see constant
interviews in Us Media with their
families we never hear about people like
this this young girl Dia Abu dun Abu Mo
Mosen who was interviewed days before
she was killed and said her dream was to
be a doctor and get to get a prosthetic
and walk and become a doctor so she
could help other people like herself and
here is what Israel did with her dreams
why so we're doing everything we can to
bring the other side of the story which
I think is much closer to reality to you
uh with very little
resources and uh it's all there at the
gry zone.com and are and on our YouTube
channel you can follow us on Twitter at
uh the greyzone news at we have an
Instagram Channel as well highly
recommend everybody go checks uh bun of
your work out couple more questions
human Shields you often hear this just
repeated over and over how do you like
to address
that well there's there's been no
evidence of human shield Feld is is
understood in the traditional sense of a
gunman actually operating deliberately
behind civilians in order to gain cover
in the Gaza Strip except when the
Israelis have done it on camera in
jabalia taking men out of their homes
taking their shirts off and forcing them
to march in front of them or strapping
them with explosives and force forcing
them to go into tunnels ahead of them
because they're too cowardly to face the
alasam fighters themselves we have that
on camera Us Media won't show it then we
have just the whole concept of human
Shields that Israel is applying where oh
Hamas member meaning you basically like
it's like you belong to the conservative
or labor party you belong to hamas's
political party so we're GNA bomb your
entire family and say that your family
were human Shields well let's flip that
on its head Israeli soldiers are walking
around in Israeli cities going to
amusement parks and beaches with their
guns and their uniforms so let's say
Hamas had an Air Force they'd be able to
bomb the entire Beach and pretty much
every Home and Office Building inside
Israel if they applied Israel's
genocidal logic of human Shields they
pulled out they pulled out in 2005 2006
they left them they could have made this
into a vacation resort they could have
made it a paradise on
earth right right right yeah there would
there was going to be a a Trump Tower in
the jabalia refugee camp if they had
just sat there and enjoyed their
occupation and enjoyed being controlled
by Israel forever no this whole like the
the US and UK policy I mean UK policy is
the US policy US policy on Gaza is
Guided by a few basic racist principles
one of which is that Palestinians are
just supposed to accept being controlled
by Israel forever because Israel is the
state that was granted to because of the
Holocaust in the Bible and Joe Biden
accepts that logic and there therefore
October 7th was unacceptable along with
every form of resistance including the
great March of return When Palestinians
just basically tried to march to their
lands that had been taken from them in
Israel without weapons and were all
sniped shot had their legs taken out
from under them were paralyzed were
killed so no form of resistance is
acceptable they just need to accept
Israeli control and the benevolent
Master will give them wealth and allow
them to be a Singapore on the
Mediterranean
because that's just there I mean where's
the where's the pretext for that where
has that ever happened before ladies and
gentle gentlemen this is Max Blumenthal
here with us awardwinning journalist go
to the gry Zone check them out Max thank
you so much thanks so much for having me
on I cannot leave without giving you a
gift if you're not yet Muslim and you
tune in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go ahead and visit theen
show.com we'll take care of the postage
and everything and get it delivered to
you and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at800
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum